The Joe Rogan Experience let me tell you
something when you're the first guided
I'm the first guy to do what I did yes
you know I mean I always looked up to
Eddie Murphy I think he's the absolute
greatest from stand up to to the films
he's done and that's sort of the career
I want that I figured I would just go
from doing you know uh millions of
people on the road to just movie stardom
you know but
you know I got the backlash you know you
were the first to get the back yeah but
yeah I was the first man from MTV so Ben
from MTV Ben from MTV for jokes let me
you're bringing up stuff I want to bring
up but let me all right so with the MTV
this is what you'll love this is the
part you don't know
well didn't they approve that set
anywhere no they didn't move anything
they didn't know no see
you know this is the thing you know I
always had an expression nobody [__]
with dice dice does the [__] in the
past
the president
the future in a day
dice ultimately in the Multiverse does
the [__] that's it in the Multiverse
so I come for the rehearsal
and my whole job was to hit my mark
and ladies and gentlemen
I remember the last Puritan
share and I make that move with my hand
right yeah
okay
so I'm getting ready and that uh they
already had a couple comics on that just
tanked you know polarize it and I think
he's great but
you don't come out on the MTV Awards at
the universal Amphitheater and talk
about the hats Sinatra War
I'm looking at my friend going look at
look at the crowd nobody it's like he's
not even in the room
you know my friend says to me he goes
well
you could go out there and you could
either be a teardrop
well you could be a tidal wave you know
you
Okay so
I don't really want to go nuts I'm
trying to do the right thing I got the
biggest manager ever Sandy gallon who
had everybody from whoopee to Stallone
to Dolly Parton I mean I'm sure you know
the name Sandy gallon okay
so biggest manager in Hollywood so I'm
trying to do the right thing
and um
so now I don't know a minute before I go
out arsenio's the host
Here Comes Dick Clark who wow it's Dick
Clark you know you grow up watching this
man
and he comes over just to hear him call
me dice was hilarious
and he goes look nice
if you got a stretch Arsenio will come
over to you and you'll play around and
go whoa wait a minute what do you mean
stretch stretch what you know what am I
stretching my dick what are you doing no
I'm not even kidding he goes no you know
because Cher might not be ready I go no
no we didn't work anything out me and
Arsenio and I had no problem with
Arsenio but you know this is a
standalone spot you know and he goes
well this is the way things are I go
don't [__] tell me how things go okay
you're not my boss you know and as I'm
getting angry at him which in my mind
I'm going are you really getting angry
at Dick Clark
they start introducing me
well I come out then now I'm angry now
everybody's going to pay now everybody
will be disciplined and I don't know how
I did the set but I went into the poems
now you got to understand this is not
HBO or Showtime this is MTV this is
everybody gets this it's free you know I
go into the poems and uh what was the
poem uh
oh that got me banned I go Georgie Porgy
putting in pie jerked off in his
girlfriend's eye whenever I was dry and
shut Georgie [__] that one-eyed [__]
oh and the crowd's going [__] crazy
so I figured go into my fat girl stuff
and that ended with you don't know where
the tits begin and the belly ends it's
like one big glop of [__] right and I go
now I go because they gave me a signal
ladies and gentlemen the last Puritan
share and she comes out singing If I
Could Turn Back Time which is what
everybody was thinking in the room if we
could turn back time about eight minutes
but in the meantime while I'm doing the
ACT
Dick Clark goes to charge me and Arsenio
jumps on his back and tackles him the
car's trying to stop yourself the clock
was gonna jump he went out of his
[__] mind
messy I'll put it to you that way
so now now I come off the stage Eddie
right
Jamie listen Jamie young Jamie young
Jamie so now they're taking me into the
Press tents
not one question was asked
and and it was all the press in the
world
Sandy gown calls me at home he goes
I was praying that what I was watching
on TV was only coming through my
television
then I get a call
you know from a club owner remember
Rascals and Western the owner Mark
Magnum yeah great greatest guy
so Kennison was there who
I always say he was having a rivalry
with me I was happy for him when his
career took off I was thrilled for him
he had no problem with me because I was
on the show Crime Story at the time
but and he was doing I don't know four
or five thousand seats a night he was
the guy before I took off when my career
took off it went straight to Arenas I
was doing 80 to 100 000 people a week
and he just couldn't handle it for
whatever reason but he goes so
kennison's watching this going that's it
he's done he's finished in the meantime
the reality was I went from doing one
arena show let's let's say at the
Spectrum in Philly the two Arena shows
but three Arena shows where Bill Burr
saw me at um in Boston at whatever Arena
I did there I had one show it went to
three shows it just got bigger and
bigger and bigger nothing was hurting
and so the next day there's this big
meeting at MTV and Rick Rubin was there
you know and you know my my people that
I worked with uh Sandy got all these but
it was the president that banning me for
life you know which is hilarious I'm not
even a singer you know and uh yeah I'm
like some band what do I give a [__]
look at the numbers right and um but
Dick Clark This is why Dick Clark became
Dick Clark because the guy that was
trying to tackle and beat me to a pulp
for what I was doing is standing there
his hair is now fixed the next day
and he says to a room full of Executives
when they're banning me for life he goes
are you sure you want to do that because
Rick Rubin told me he goes this guy is
the biggest thing in the world right now
and you're Banning him for life it was
just one of the crazy moments of the
backlash of my career